Jupiter's fourth-largest moon Europa
looks just as uninviting as any other
place in the outer solar system
covered in ice the moon's surface is
colder than the coldest spot on earth by
more than 100 degrees Celsius but under
that icy exterior maybe vast oceans of
liquid water and a seafloor bustling
with active volcanoes and hydrothermal
vents what that means is Europa could
hold the right stuff for life Europa's
potential for life hasn't escaped
scientists attention but the moon's
frigid and rigid exterior poses a
problem it may be roughly 20 kilometers
thick as thick as 53 Empire State
Building stacked on top of each other at
that thickness the ice sheet will be
difficult to Pierce melt or drill
through the constraints sound daunting
but that hasn't stopped teams of
scientists from engineering fantastic
experiments to get the job done one team
is taking a modest yet impactful
approach penetrate Europa's ice and
infiltrate it with tiny experiments the
Hulk would neither learn about the ice
or even hit pockets or vents of liquid
water and discover organisms within
called the ice penetrator delivery
system a rocket-powered spaceship would
drop a 20 kilogram canister about the
size of a two-liter bottle at the frozen
moon at about 300 meters per second once
inside the ice the cannister would use a
microscope and tools to study the
chemistry of its surroundings another
way to crack the ice is to melt your way
in call the cryo bot this ice melting
machine would be about as long as a
compact car and looks something like a
telephone pole aluminum blocks on the
tube domed head would melt ice suck in
hot water and then shoot it out to melt
more ice to get through ultra cold ice
team would have to use a nuclear power
source but for now they're using laser
energy channel through a fiber optic
cable so far the solution seems to work
once through the ice the cryo BOTS would
launch a tiny submarine into your
opacity potions to search for signs of
life but some sign
just think drilling into europa is an
easier way to get through the ice the
drill however couldn't be anything like
what is now used to get at Earth's deep
reservoirs of oil and gas instead the
auto gopher is a wire line drill
that's 2 metres long weighs 22 kilograms
and has an 8 - through ice and if those
teeth wear down the drill can pound the
bit into rock like a hammer
the drilling can all be done with less
energy than a hairdryer uses and the
equipment can ultimately move samples of
crushed up ice into a tube with
electronics to analyze the chemistry of
the moon still with all that ingenuity
these proposed tools still have to get
to Europa and that may be the biggest
challenge of all but if they get there
and if they find life we could be
looking at another Copernican like
revolution showing us that life may be
more abundant than we thought